now I would say a slightly surprised
appears Morgan's doing it because he I
don't know if you know he's a big Donald
Trump supporter and I know you're not a
fan I'm really not I'm really not no I
am I am reminded of a time
um about five years ago I was at a
dinner with my ex-wife Brooke and her
family and this and that and about
halfway through I I I noticed
um
Donald
um staring at my watch
and so he started saying you know listen
I'm uh I'm I'm sorry that I wasn't
invited to your wedding this and that
I'm sorry I can't make your wedding and
I'm like I didn't invite you um so he
says but you know I want to give you a
uh an early wedding gift as a gesture
for me and Melania and she doesn't say a
word she's very sweet and very pretty
but just kind of sits there you know
yeah uh anywho so uh so he says these
are uh these are platinum diamond Harry
Winston and he pulls off his cufflinks
and he gives them to me and so I'm like
oh gosh Mr Trump you really shouldn't do
this because no no it's the least I can
do and you know have a great marriage
and all that little did he know
um so so smash cut to about six months
later I had a uh some jewelry getting
appraise at the house you know and and
and she finished and was leaving
and and I said oh yeah you know there's
there's another a couple of pieces that
I have that I'm that I'm very curious
about could would you mind appraising
these she said now uh what are they I
said well you know I explained the
dinner and this and that these are from
Donald Trump Harry Winston you know
Flawless D's Platinum she she took the
loop uh spent about four seconds and and
kind of recoiled from it uh much like
people do from Trump and um so so she
says uh in in in their finest moment
this is cheap pewter and and and bad
zirconias and their stamp Trump and I
just thought I just thought what does
this really say about the man you know
um that he said here's like a great
wedding gift and it's just it's just a
bag of dog [ __ ] you know
now is it is it is that the laughter I
can hear coming from across the pond at
our country about this charlatan
there's it's scary times all over the
place but we're having very scary times
yeah but I have faith that that that
that good indecent people will make the
right choice and the circus will leave
town before it uh contaminates the Over
law for that
he's hot man can I just say I think I
think we've spent too long now this is
wrong you've gone to it this long
discussing someone
oh